[Musik]
der besitzer dieser bierflasche auf
rädern ist ein lebenslustiger mensch
habe auf den tod hat er sich vorbereitet
wie kaum ein anderer
denn in diesem gefährt wird martin
brunnschweiler eines tages seine letzte
reise antreten
[Musik]
es ist seltsam
nein es ist sehr bequem ich weiß
wahrscheinlich sieht es für einige leute
gruselig aus aber das stört mich nicht
am ende wird der tod jeden ereilen das
ist eben die realität
man sollte es einfach etwas leichter
nehmen der 47 jährige brite hat sein
leben dem bier gewidmet er braut bier
auf der isle of man vor 30 jahren hat
ihm sein bruder das passende gefährt
dazu gebastelt aus einem alten citroen
wurde die fahrende bierflasche die hier
auf der insel jeder kennt dann hörte er
von einer firma die särge auf und spart
es ist ein kunstwerk und ich bin stolz
dieses fahrzeug für meine letzte reise
zu haben
ich mag dieses innenfutter es ist sehr
luxuriös anfertigen ließ er sich seine
kuriose kiste bereits vor sechs jahren
man kann sehen dass es alles handgemacht
ist
alle diese kleinen details aus holz
wirklich alles diese kleinen
scheibenwischer die spiegel ich liebe
die malereien es ist alles von hand
gemalt ich liebe das ganze gebaut wurde
der außergewöhnliche sarg im englischen
nottingham in der sarg manufaktur weg
von unter der marke crazy car fans sind
in den letzten jahren mehrere 100
verrückte särge entstanden
gemeinsam mit seinen kollegen entwirft
und baut john woraus die friedhofs
hingucker dies wird ein flugzeug
zwischen 1000 und 3500 euro kostet so
ein handgemachtes unikat
ich denke dass technisch
herausforderndste wahl der rolls royce
weil wir für alles eigene frau mitmachen
mussten sogar für die schutzbleche wir
mussten sie biegen ausprobieren was
klappt und dann kleben
also da steckt wirklich viel arbeit drin
im lagerraum der sagt manufaktur stehen
neben kopien auch originale die auf
ihren einsatz warten
oft können die trauergäste später
leichter raten was der verstorbene im
leben besonders schätzte oder was sein
größter unerfüllter traum wahr
[Musik]
der mann der das hier bestellt hat ist
ein großer blackpool fern das ist ein
fußballklub logan
er ist noch quicklebendig da war hier
mit schon auf einigen ausstellungen
doch nicht alles ist amüsant manchmal
müssen die sagt mache auch mit ihren
gefühlen kämpfen vor allem wenn es um
kinder geht
[Musik]
das war das musikinstrument eines kindes
dann erfährt man dass es plötzlich
gestorben ist wir hatten nicht viel zeit
es herzustellen
das ist dann ziemlich traurig für sich
selbst hat schon wo es noch keinen sack
gemacht auch wenn er schon klare
vorstellungen hat
wenn ich mir einen bauen würde dann wäre
es wahrscheinlich ein ferrari rennwagens
ich liebe verrat ist irgendwann mache
ich das vielleicht das wäre lustig schon
jetzt seine beerdigung als einen
gelungenen abgang vorzubereiten diese
verrückte idee hat martin brunnschweiler
seiner frau zunächst verschwiegen
doch dann machte er eine ausstellung
über seine brauerei und der sarg durfte
nicht fehlen
meine frau findet das nicht gut
sie hält es für mag aber sie denkt nicht
gerne über solche dinge nach
ich freute es wenn ich weiß wenn ich
gehe dann gibt es für all meine freunde
in die menschen die ich kenne genug bier
dafür werde ich sorgen es ist doch schön
ist dann allen so leicht zu machen wie
es eben geht
er ist bestens vorbereitet doch der
brite will noch lange leben und seinen
biersack höchstens zum probeliegen
nutzen